lots of bitcoin skeptics and critics
came together and they were all yelling
and screaming about bitcoin mining and
all that energy consumption well the
bitcoin miners they jumped into action
and they put together the bitcoin mining
council really what they're trying to do
here is collect data and publicize it so
that people get a more accurate view of
exactly what's going on in the bitcoin
industry that bitcoin mining council
just released their new survey that
shows exactly what's been happening over
the last year or so the single best
summary of it was a quote from michael
saylor microstrategy ceo in the quote
here's what he said in the first quarter
of 2022 the hash rate and related
security of the bitcoin network improved
by 23 year on year while energy usage
decreased 25
we observed a 63 year-on-year increase
in efficiency due to advances in
semi-conductor technology the rapid
expansion of north american mining the
china exodus and the worldwide adoption
of sustainable energy and modern bitcoin
mining techniques ultimately that idea
that the bitcoin mining network grew by
23 but the energy consumption dropped by
25 percent means that bitcoin mining's
just becoming much more efficient as
bitcoin mining becomes more and more
integrated into everyday lives and into
local economies and starts to actually
play a material role in stabilizing
electric grids around the united states
and globally what we're likely to see is
that more capital and innovation will
pour into this industry and bitcoin
money will become more and more
efficient if we can continue to grow
year over year this efficiently then
bitcoin miners are going to have the
upper hand against the critics and
skeptics at the end of the day all
bitcoin needs is for the truth to be
told as you see with the bitcoin mining
council bitcoiners can solve any problem
they can defend against any attack they
simply need to come together open source
the information and publicize it for
anyone to come and audit and that's
exactly what we're seeing in this
bitcoin mining council survey it's that
bitcoin miners not only are they more
efficient today than they were a year
ago but they also are using more than 50
sustainable renewable power and at the
end of the day bitcoin mining is way
ahead of other industries which average
around 20 use of those renewable energy
sources and so bitcoin mining will
continue to be the brunt of a lot of
jokes and a lot of attacks but bitcoin
doesn't care it produces block after
block after block of transactions
completely ignoring any of those attacks
the miners they're doing god's work they
continue to make the network more
efficient more secure and at the end of
the day i think that the bitcoin miners
are going to prevail and the skeptics
and critics will eventually capitulate
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time